now i'll take this as my cue
eccentricity what is eccentricity
it's a it's a ratio what's it the ratio
between
okay it's the ratio between two
distances namely
from some point on the locus right
wherever that is p
to where so the focus and then
from p2 good okay so we would say
ps and pd right
so the way that we wrote that rather
than saying
where did we start what was the first
conic section that we started looking at
remember there's a parabola
right
so for the parabola
what was the eccentricity equal to for
such a shape
equal to one okay and the reason why is
because a parabola by definition the
locus definition is
ps equals pd the distances are the same
the ratio
is one to one okay so in other words
the s d was equal to one
okay now let's cover a bit more recent
round
how do we end up with an ellipse what
did we do
okay we adjusted the eccentricity to
now we tried out a half
um tess
okay and what we ended up with was an
ellipse
okay now that's what we're going to pick
up so what i hope you can find is
uh where you've got some of your
diagrams drawn in that kind of thing we
need a bit more language
to be able to start to talk about this
thing okay now
the parabola the ellipse there are two
more conic sections that we're going to
look at
but there are so many questions raised
by the ellipse but what we're going to
do is we're sort of going to
stop pause there a little for a little
while sort of chew on it and see what we
can
learn basically okay don't worry we'll
get to
get direct into my hype level in time
yeah this is what we're going to focus
on for now
get it
i've been seriously doing that all day
like it's just my brain
all right now go back find where you've
drawn one of your ellipses and if you
can't
in recent book draw yourself a new one
for now just put it center on the origin
ah that's pretty old
okay now let's put some tags on this so
we can actually um
talk about this that kind of thing right
the general form
of an ellipse okay is very very similar
to the general form so i'm talking about
the equation
the general form of the equation of
ellipse is very similar to the general
form of the equation
of a circle right and we noticed that
and i think what we end up with
correct me if i'm wrong was it was that
four maybe
was it three it was three yeah
okay you're looking at something like
this and the reason why you put in this
form
rather than having say r squared you
know for a circle on the right hand side
is well can anyone tell me i can think
of at least two reasons why is this a
more helpful form to have things in
okay maybe i should ask in more guided
way what would be the problem
with trying to have like a number like
like r squared
over here what's the issue with an
ellipse
yeah and this doesn't have a radius okay
in the way that a circle does
okay because it's like well this
distance and that distance is not all
the same
because the locus is defined in a
different way okay so there's your first
problem
the second thing that this is helpful
with is once you want to find the
intercepts it's super easy once you put
in x equals zero and y equals zero
it more or less leaps out attitude okay
in fact once you've got some practice
and some of you might already be at this
point
if you want to work out the y intercepts
okay you've let x equal zero okay and
you can see
that vanishes so you're left with um
y equals y equals
plus or minus two
yes okay and i can repeat it um
for my x-intercepts
okay so this is nice as a form okay
all right now being that i've got this
kind of information on here let's try
and generalize so you notice i haven't
put anything on here
so instead of three and four i'm going
to call this
the general x x squared on a squared
plus y squared on b squared equals one
okay
now this is centered on the origin
we'll look at um horizontal vertical
shifts afterwards
think about what these numbers are and
what these numbers are and what
significance
there is here where would you expect to
find
a where is it on the diagram
where's a what distance or what length
gives you a
it's think be careful it sometimes does
refer to focal length
but that's kind of with the parabola
isn't it right
a or rather plus or minus a refers to
your x-intercepts
right so there ought to be a over here
and minus a
over here catch it in the same way
you're gonna have minus b and b
okay now very briefly at the end of last
lesson we talked a bit about the
symmetry that you get with the ellipse
okay we talked about how you're gonna
have not one but two
foci and not one but two directricies
okay so being that you've got this kind
of symmetry it helps to be able to talk
about the axis of symmetry
right so in a circle
all the axes of symmetry are more or
less equal okay
but here there are a couple of important
ones okay
so let's look at this one this one here
wow that's a really bad line okay now
that's one of the axes of symmetry
in my diagram it's the longer one okay
and by the way by convention
this is a bit tricky a is meant to refer
to
the larger axis of symmetry okay so
that's why i've drawn it out as my wider
one
if i were to draw one which was taller
strictly speaking
the a squared should be here okay but
you'll pick that up as you start doing
questions
because it's the bigger axis they call
it the major axis
okay now we noticed this idea of you
know
a circle has a diameter and has a radius
but it has a major axis but you can't
call it a radius
yeah so instead this half distance here
which is the longest uh the furthest
distance you can get from the center
anywhere on the lips since it's half of
the major axis
they call it the semi-major axis
okay question what is the length of the
semi-major axis
it's just a isn't it okay which tells
you that the major axis is
2a it's not rocket science
okay now likewise
no big prizes for guessing um
what this length nothing down here i'm
kind of running out of space in colors
so i'm going to draw it over here
what this axis in the middle from minus
b to b
what do you think it might be called a
minor axis
because we're in this class because
we're imaginative
that's right minor axis half of it
semi-minor axis
okay and likewise the city minor axis is
equal to b
okay now we have some language to talk
about this thing right
we want to just basically explore it
what can we learn about this thing
what kinds of mysteries does it have if
we can try and dig out okay now
here's a question i'm going to post to
you okay i'll i'll read it out to you
and then i just want you to listen to it
try and get a sense of what it's
actually saying and then i'll get you to
write it down
you can write a short form if you like
whatever captures the essence of the
question here's my question
we can determine the equation of an
ellipse
given some of its geometric properties
okay pause say that again
we can determine the equation of the
lips this guy right
given some of its properties what
properties did we use before
to land on this there were three of them
properties features attributes whatever
you want to call this
okay so all right number one we use the
eccentricity so we said half
okay and then see what happens but there
were two other features that defined it
okay focus or we started with one and
then you get the other one okay
and uh okay good so we started with
these
okay and that gave us an equation
okay so now my question to you is
can we go the other way what if i gave
you an equation
could you determine what the
eccentricity and focus
and directrix are
now intuitively alternating probably if
you can go in one direction
usually in mass you can go the other way
it's not always true
right you know when you were doing
industry last year
you're probably like okay you're
wrapping your head around you can go in
one direction
it's not exactly the same the other way
okay here though we ought to be able to
okay so why don't you do i'm gonna get
you to spend two three minutes
don't use this one we already know what
the facts for that one are okay
um pick some different numbers pick
something that isn't going to be too
hard for you
something like i don't know x squared on
whatever
okay something like that that's really
standard
could you try and work out what it's
eccentricity and
focus slash focus directrix directions
ah how would you even go about it where
would you start
i want you to think about it first see
how far you can get on your own steam
and then i'll walk you through how i
would do it okay off you go